today's topic i'm maddie and i'm tina
maddy's mom what are you doing today um
my mom is going to guess who
i have slept with
no i mean if
i was one of the people who banged i
might be like
[Music]
listen but if i'm with your mom
you bring your mom to the cut and she
has to guess who you bang
hey mom guess how much of a hoe i've
been
[Laughter]
one hey but maybe this is the future
maybe we're just so open sexually and
all this stuff
your parents are going to know i mean
you know maybe it's just me i just don't
want to hear what my kids looks like
like that
like we can have the conversation about
it but i don't want to hear in depthly
who you banged and how it was and
i don't know i get it is your daughter
open about this sort of thing she talks
to me when she's dating somebody
but she's private about the sex part
do you know sexual orientation i said
bicycle
but then you said no i kind of just
consider myself gay
because i feel like i'm more attracted
to women and that's
mostly who i date how do you feel about
that i think that's great
look at all these people some of them
have slept with your daughter
how many people have you slept with i'd
have to really go back in my memory
and like think about it what's up with
some of these girls talking like they
just woke up all the time
i was really just um you know uh
feeling a bit like strange about
you know getting coffee maybe
i don't know if i don't know if
maybe we should go for a lot of things
there's a lot of girls that speak like
that
danny
throwback hey hi i'm tina i'm ebony nice
to meet you
nice to meet you too so how do you know
maddie we met at a new year's eve party
what do you find attractive about her
her eyes that was the first thing i
noticed when i met her and
her hair complements them sense of style
that's everything really
hello hey seattle okay i thought that
was you
do you know this person yes very very
good friends in school
hung out together do you know if this
person has slept with your daughter or
not
i don't i don't think so i think you're
friends
you want to do a test oh okay yes you
can go sit by daddy oh
okay okay play with each other's hair
except for don't mess up maddie's bangs
yeah i gelled them
do you want to do the ultimate test say
now kiss each other
i'll ask maddie if she wants to do you
want to kiss seattle yeah
yeah i thought it was a good touch by
the mother
you what i was good touched by the
mother yeah yeah i'll ask her i thought
that was good like the way the producer
was getting like three people like you
want me to watch
excuse me i'm still the mom here yeah
okay i ask if she's allowed or she's
comfortable thank you very much sir so
i mean i mean kudos to her for that yes
i think it's good to be able to
that's one thing that always pees me
about kids is just like removing their
agency like
not even just with like this kind of
situation but like kids and like an
uncle comes by and says come here
and the kid's like no and the uncle just
like defies those boundaries i thought
it was great
parenting in that regards that's the
thing that's the thing like in the
haitian community as well
like we have to say hello to everybody
like people i don't know yeah i have to
say what's up and hug
yeah like i've seen once in my life
maybe when i was
it's just yeah sometimes it's just yeah
so that was good on her part
all right let's get you back out here
well
i still think no you have not slept with
my daughter
okay hello how are you
do you know this person yes lionel's
been friends with maddie
since sophomore year very good friends
would it shock you if i slept with your
daughter yes because when you're
together i don't like pick up on any of
that
he bring the mom too
cause just in the way he said
how would you feel about if i spent with
your daughter it was something about
that energy would it shock you if i
slept with your daughter
yes because when you're together i don't
like pick up on any of that
kind of actual energy together
it's just it's more just like friends
and
where did you meet we met on tinder
actually
um ask if she has any pets oh do you
have pets
yes we have a snake at our house i have
a fish
see i know maddie loves snakes and fish
oh yeah
come out here maddie me oh up there yeah
okay slow dance
ah yes mom
old timer mom slow dance ain't nobody
slow dance no more
yeah nobody does that she wanted to know
if there's some romance between the make
or twerk
thank you tick tock
what's your simple orientation um i'm
queer have you ever slept with a woman
i guess technically yeah what does that
mean well like not like
not like you mean like in a bed together
sleeping
like not like not like penetrating do
you think they messed around
i don't think you slept with maddie i
understand
it's not personal tina hi sarah sarah
sarah okay i know i've met you before
yes
okay so let's see what's your
orientation
i'm queer okay what's your sexual
straight all right
i like i should cut her off to say that
yeah yeah straight straight
straight how do you feel about donating
that and no hold straight straight
straight what about fingers no no
straight no cream filling straight
straight straight straight
straight pull out your finger [ __ ] i
got nubs no fingers straight
straight no popsicles [ __ ] straight
like that's what it felt like cheers
what are you thinking i'm i'm on the
fence does maddie have any
tattoos no no no
no
[Laughter]
yo the producers in the cutter getting
creepier and creepier as these videos
get more ambitious
put some cream on it i felt like he was
behind the camera doing this thing
[Laughter]
i think yes do you think it was like a
one-night stand or do you think it was
like a recurring theme
but you're not the one that's supposed
to ask questions yeah but you know what
she's asking that because they hate it
for a while
i'm mad at you yeah yeah she wants to
know yeah yeah i ain't maddie i wouldn't
be surprised if they still dating yeah
maybe a couple times
okay
who is this person do you know this
person so i know chloe and maddie
were in a relationship do you think they
they had
each other yes
yes okay all right all right the red
yeah the red the guy yeah
the black yeah uh her yeah and her yeah
yeah all right we got the same go ahead
and get back in the line
raise your hand if you slept with my
daughter look at all those people slept
with your daughter
woohoo
too bad they didn't throw curveball with
the dude
maybe there's no curveball yeah anything
you can't invent a curveball that's fair
well she said she did sleep with a dude
before
hmm
i think the prospect of doing this in
front of my mom is just crazy which i
think
that's where most people are going to
come from i would never do that's nasty
but some people got different
relationships with their parent
i know some people who walk around naked
around their parents i know some people
who still get bathed by their parents as
they're adults i know some people
you know who share all their details
with their parents yes i've seen that
you know so it's just even you going in
my family
you would see that like we different
yeah
the way we talk to each other we crack
joke yeah so it's just levels to this
there's some people
like in my family where we never even
talked about any kind of form of
sexual contact ever ever and there's
other families where they talk about
everything and they're super open
and uh i think that spectrum is okay
it's not because you're on one end at
the end and is necessarily disgusting
it's just different
i could never see that which is why i
mean me cringe but i'm cringing
because of my personal experience not
because they're actually cringing does
that make sense
i see that yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't
even if i'm really open with my parents
i wouldn't do this game with my mom no
but you know there was this uh there's
anyways there was this dad and his son
on on facebook who i used to watch and
they used to talk about how the other
ones
wasn't the only thing about it and i
just thought it was hilarious just how
awkward it is
but you know some people like you know
what i'm talking about
yeah now these dirty
yeah but dad but dad i need some more
money i don't go
[ __ ] i got tonight i was like what
that's how they talk to each other
that's the relationship hilarious you're
funny but you know
some people like that are you going to
be like that with your kids do you think
i mean can we have it in between like i
don't have to be like
all the way talking to and all the you
know i'm going to be in somewhere in the
middle
yeah you're not going to dye your hair
pink and be like come on talk to me
about your problems julie no where did
he touch you where did he penetrate
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna be
like uh cold uh be safe
you know what i mean there's a problem
you can come to me but other than that
you know you got your friends
i'm probably gonna have a better
relationship with my kids
than my parents have with me but i'm
still not one of your little friends
yeah you know what i mean so but i'm
gonna definitely compete with my son
if he brings home a hot grandma try to
bang her you're gonna try to bang her
what
i'm mad at you i know you would that's
why i let them know what else in life
look like listen
alpha male 1
she's going to be of age obviously chill
out but you know yeah i hope
it's like every one of those porn videos
where they're at the aisle in the girls
in the room
and the dad comes what's wrong susie
aren't you going to marry my son she's
like
but i've been dreaming about you
what i wanted one thing i wanted to say
was about the mom i think i liked her
approach
she was open but you could tell she was
uncomfortable with some of this stuff
but she stayed respectful
and she thought about her daughter's
boundaries so i think as far as
parenting goes like
i really like that that aspect of it but
uh we want to hear what you guys think
in the comments below would you guys
ever
do this with your kids or with your
parents are you guys that open and what
do you guys think do you think it's good
or bad
um i personally enjoy most of my
intimacy to be fairly personal but some
people are different i don't think
that's necessarily bad but
i want to hear your thoughts
[Music]